FBI agent Peter struck gets clocked by a
bevy of Republicans President Trump
takes on Teresa May for no apparent
reason and we checked the mailbag I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
man oh man when the news is this stupid
it's not hard to do a show and we have
lots to get to today but we begin first
with reminding you that your employees
could be better now mine could my
employees are just spectacular I mean
they made a video yesterday that is so
good I can't stop talking about it but
if they ever displease me and we'll go
directly to zip recruiter and we will
replace them forthwith the way we will
do that is by going to zip recruiter and
listing our job and then zip recruiter
sends our job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards they don't stop there
with their powerful matching technology
zip recruiter scans thousands of resumes
to find people with the right experience
and invite them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one and spotlights the top
candidates see never miss a great match
zipper career is so effective that 80%
of employers who post on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate through the site
within the first day so with results
like that it's no wonder the zip
recruiter is the highest rated hiring
site in America we use it here at daily
wire right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this web address
zip recruiter com daily wire okay try it
for free zip recruit calm slash daily
where we use it here at the daily wire
so that makes sense zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire zip recruiter is indeed
the smartest way to hire we use it here
at the office and you should as well zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire and you
can try zip recruiter for free also
wanted to remind you that our next
episode of the conversation is coming up
quickly this Tuesday July 17 5:30 p.m.
Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific all of your
questions will be answered by our own
Andrew Clavin with our host Alisha
Krause
our live Q&A is available on YouTube and
Facebook for everybody to watch only
subscribers can ask through questions at
daily wire.com you can check out the pin
comments on this video for more
information once again subscribe ask
drew live questions Tuesday July 17th at
5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific
join the conversation ask drew where all
of his hair went and why he names his
book so poorly go check it out the
conversation happening next Tuesday 5:30
p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific all right
so yesterday Peter struck you remember
this guy this is the guy who's an FBI
agent having an affair with another FBI
agent and he was texting with her the
whole time about how much he hated
Donald Trump and this only matters
because Peter struck was in charge of
both the Hillary Clinton email
investigation as well as the Trump
Russia collusion investigation and as
you will also recall the Inspector
General of the DOJ Michael Horowitz
found that Peters strux bias against
President Trump
not be counted out when it came to
analyzing his activities with regard to
these investigations so for example
there was a point in in late September
when it became clear to the FBI that
there were Hillary Clinton emails on
Huma Abedin computer instead of
prioritizing that and checking it out
Peter struck decided it was imperative
to put all of his resources on the
supposed Trump Russia collusion that was
happening and instead of checking out
the Hillary thing you tracked out the
Trump thing that's away the Hillary
thing until late in the election cycle
ironically that ended up boosting
Hillary Clinton out of the presidency it
ended up creating a Donald Trump
presidency possibly by allowing the FBI
and James Comey to Rhea nounce an
opening of Hillary's email investigation
like five six days before the election
actually happened so Peter struck is
he's the guy who wrote that he would
stop Trump from becoming president he
was the guy who wrote that all of these
ignorant hillbillies we're gonna vote
for Trump he's a real joy to behold so
he shows up on the hill yesterday and
he's testifying in front of the house
Government Oversight Committee let me
say at the outset I don't think that
this was a useful hearing the reason I
don't think this is a useful hearing is
because no new information was available
we already knew what Peter struck was
going to say about all of this because
it said all of it in the Inspector
General report the only thing that would
have been useful is if the members of
the House Committee on Oversight if the
Government Oversight Committee if they'd
actually asked struck about specific
instances of decision making and whether
those decisions were biased by his
anti-trump hatred right so if they'd
actually had in front of them like a
complete timeline of Peter Struck's
decision making from the initiation of
the Hillary Clinton email investigation
and the Russia collusion investigation
all the way through today and said okay
here's all your decisions here's why
this one seems biased explain yourself
that would have been useful instead what
it turned into was a lot of
grandstanding and browbeating it did
however make Peter struck look pretty
terrible because Peter struck is it
turns out a garbage human and when I say
he's a garbage humor Hume and I say this
advisedly yeah there's a moment
yesterday when louie gohmert got a lot
of flack because louie gohmert went
after struck and he went after struck
for cheating on his wife and and you
know then texting with this this lover
about donald trump all the way through
here was here was representative Gohmert
from texas going after struck yesterday
is the disgrace and it won't be
recaptured anytime soon
because of the damage you've done to the
Justice assessment and I've talked to
FBI agents around the country you've
embarrassed them you've embarrassed
yourself and I can't help but wonder
when I see you looking there with a
little smirk so how many times did you
look so innocent into your wife's eyes
and lied to her about mr. chairman it's
outrageous
yeah and Democrats go crazy over all of
this of course now is it ironic the
Republican members are chastising Peter
struck over having an affair when Louie
Gohmert I like Louie I'm friendly with
Louie when Louis campaigned for Roy
Moore in Alabama
when Louie was a big Trump supporter is
it a little ironic yes of course it's a
little ironic but I will point out that
I would like for there to be a standard
that adultery is bad in the country so
it doesn't really bother me the Peters
truck is getting smacked around over the
fact that he was cheating on his wife
with another FBI agent and texting
little nothing sweet nothings about
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump to her
that doesn't bother me in the slightest
okay so struck made himself look really
bad yesterday he started off the hearing
by saying that even this questioning is
a win for Vladimir Putin and he's
becoming a hero to the left because of
all of this it's sort of an Oliver North
moment from the 1980s during Mehran
contra Oliver North was the colonel who
had been involved in smuggling weapons
to the to the Contras in Nicaragua and
he was questioned by Democrats a lot of
Republicans came to his aid Peter struck
is having the same thing happened to him
even though he's kind of a yucky human
he has a bunch of Democrats who are now
rushing to defend him and talk about how
wonderful he is because he suggests that
even this line of questioning helps
Vladimir Putin I have the utmost respect
for Congress's oversight role but I
strongly believe today's hearing is just
another victory notch in Putin's belt
and another milestone in our enemies
campaign to tear America apart
yeah well there are serious questions to
be asked about Peter struck yeah I don't
think that having a hearing about
whether the FBI was biased in its
investigation is irrelevant this is the
job of the government Oversight
Committee I don't think that this is a
huge problem general eisah again this is
all grandstanding it was all very
entertaining but I don't think anybody
looked came out of this looking great
darrell Issa made Peter struck read his
texts and it was kind of hilarious and
I'm gonna just go or to go to a
and then ask you to read your own words
March 4 2016
you want me to read this yes please yes
sir
OMG he's an idiot now the pressure
really starts to finish my e hi how was
Trump other than a douche Melania miss
page said not ever going to become
president right right no no he's not
we'll stop it repeat that again no no
he's not we'll stop it so there is
struck reading back his own his own text
and obviously this is the guy who's now
proclaiming that he has no bias
everything was fine he explained his
text messages anti-trump text messages
by basically suggesting he did nothing
wrong then when he said we'll stop it
you know as a high-ranking member of the
FBI meaning Trump's campaign will stop
from from becoming president
he didn't mean me him mean the FBI he
meant the American people in general
we'll stop it you know we'll stop all of
this is that really what Peter struck
meant no that's not really what Peter
struck men but here he is lying about it
it would be his candidacy for the
president set the America would not vote
him into office right right I don't
recall writing that text well I deny
running the text what I can tell you is
that text in no way suggested that I or
the FBI would take any action to
influence the candidates is a fantastic
answer tool question nobody out okay so
the struck they're saying I didn't I
didn't buy it but that's the point okay
so here is that that actual little
exchange where Gowdy says Tim that's a
great answer to the question nobody
asked but that's the only question that
matters honestly the only question that
matters is not whether Peter struck
hated Donald Trump we know Peter struck
hated Donald Trump I'll bet that are a
bunch of people in the FBI who weren't
real fond to Hillary Clinton either the
real question is was the investigation
biased and this is why I say that I
think this hearing was kind of a waste
of time because it didn't get to the
question of whether his actual actions
impacted the actions of the FBI in the
Russia investigation and for that we're
gonna have to wait for more information
to come out now is it demonstrate that
Peter struck is the worst yeah the guy's
pretty much the worst I mean he there's
there's a gift going around a Jif going
around of Peter struck making these
weird faces and it's like Kevin Spacey
from 7:00 I mean the guy's weirdo but
does that actually answer the question
as to whether the Russia
investigation was from the very outset
poisoned by the FBI directed at making
sure that Trump was not president
corruptly investigated now I have my
suspicions but those suspicions were not
actually provided with any evidentiary
support during this hearing and we got
to be objective in how we view this hey
yes Peter struck is terrible yes the
Democrats who defended him for all of
this are ridiculous but if you're going
to imply that Peter struck was
responsible for an investigation that
was utterly corrupt beginning to end yes
she need to show some evidence that he's
responsible for corrupt portions of the
investigation I'm waiting to hear that
because there's an actual Inspector
General report that's going to come out
about the Russia investigation and as
I've suggested not only into anywhere
out of the realm of possibility that the
Russia investigation the collusion
investigation was tainted from the
outset by struck and his anti-trump bias
I don't think that's impossible at all
what I do think is that if the
Republicans were gonna have this hearing
they should have hit him with all that
stuff they should have had that
information they should have make that
made that information public again none
of this is to suggest that struck is
innocent
I don't think struck is innocent and for
example struck was he asked how long it
started it started before how long did
it take him to start talking about
impeachment after James Comey was fired
trey Gowdy was asking him this questions
clip 7 do you remember how long it took
for you to start talking about
impeachment after Bob Muller was
appointed I don't sir one day one day
and you are talking about impeachment
okay that's true and it shows again that
struck was wildly biased against Trump
disliked President Trump we knew all of
that already so the real question was
okay so what impact did that have on the
investigation the answer probably is
some impact but we need to see the
evidence of that impact before we can
say the entire investigation needs to be
thrown out top to bottom now I don't
think the investigation is going to come
up with anything anyway I think the
investigation is likely to come up short
on a variety of issues I don't think
it's gonna reach all the way to
President Trump I don't think it's going
to show the president Trump and the
Trump campaign actively colluded with
the Russian government I don't think any
of the evidence is there for any of that
but what I do think is that Peter struck
and the FBI needs to do a much better
job of cleaning up exactly how it is
that they are that that they are
pursuing these issues because obviously
it's it's
it's dirty in the way they are pursuing
it the question is how dirty and how
impactful now it's not stopping
Democrats from defending Peter struck
Democrats are out full force depending
struck saying that struck is just a
wonderful wonderful dude we'll talk
about that in just a second first I want
to say thanks to our sponsors over a
policy genius so you need life insurance
okay it is a moral obligation for you to
have life insurance if you die and then
you don't have life insurance that is
your fault not your death but your lack
of life insurance that's something you
can take care of right now by going over
to policy genius calm right now policy
genius is the easy way to compare life
insurance online you can compare quotes
in just five minutes when it's that easy
putting it off becomes a lot harder you
can compare quotes while sitting on the
couch you can do it while you're
listening to this podcast policy genius
has helped over 4 million people shop
for insurance placed over twenty billion
dollars in coverage and they don't just
make life insurance easy they also use
disability insurance and renter's
insurance and health insurance if you
care about it they can cover it so go
check it out right now at policy genius
com it's the easy way to compare all the
top insurers find the best value for you
I have life insurance my wife has life
insurance I urge you seriously go get
life insurance right now you never have
to think about it again once you got it
go check it out policy genius.com no
sales pressure zero hassle and it's free
once again that's policy genius.com
there's a reason that 4 million people
shop for insurance using policy genius
and they've placed twenty billion
dollars in coverage policy genius.com
don't put it off alrighty so with all of
this said with Peter struck being as
corrupt as Peter struck is with him
being as smug as he has and the smugness
matters here hey listen I have a certain
amount of sympathy for people who are
smug considering that I am a charter
member of the smug Club but if in fact
Peter struck is really smug about what
he believes what that tends toward is a
certain level of certainty in his
activity with regard to his
professionalism and he tends to believe
that his opinion is facts which is why
he's so smug about it when he starts to
believe that your opinion is fact well
that tends to creep into a mission
mission skew it tends to allow you to
believe that the stuff you are doing is
legitimate even when it's slightly
illegitimate again we're gonna have to
wait to see the facts come out as to how
badly he botched the investigation but
I'd be very surprised if there was no
battery whatsoever Democrats however are
out defending struck because struck as a
hero so Steve Cohen who's a Democratic
congressman from I believe Tennessee he
says that that Peters
should be given a Purple Heart if I
could give you a Purple Heart I would
you deserve one this has been an attack
on you in a way to attack mr. Muller and
the investigation that is to get it
Russia collusion involved in our
election okay so that's that's that's
great the Democrats say that he deserves
a Purple Heart Purple Heart is for
wounded veterans people who've served in
the military and wounded in the line of
duty Peter struck doesn't deserve a
Purple Heart Peter struck deserves a
pink slip not a Purple Heart a pink slip
I mean the guy should be fired and this
is a guy who is disgraced the FBI no
matter how you slice it but according to
the Democrats because he sends a bunch
of anti-trump text messages he deserves
a Purple Heart
now what's hilarious about this is that
it's probably Peter Struck's fault that
Hillary Clinton is not president right
now if Peters truck had simply
investigated the Hillary Clinton email
stuff on Huma Abedin computer and
released that in early October as
opposed to the very tail end of October
then Hillary Clinton wouldn't face that
round of bad headlines at the end of
October she may very well have won so
they want to give a Purple Heart now to
the same people who may be responsible
for Donald Trump being president in the
first place it's really hilarious they
do the same thing with James Comey James
Comey was the guy who released a letter
right before the election saying Hillary
Clinton was under investigation again by
the FBI and now they love James Comey
the Left can really be bought for a song
all you have to do is scream about how
much you dislike Trump and the left
suddenly loves you the left suddenly is
just you're it's become an entry key to
the to the leftist to the leftist kind
of lounge if you are if you just like
President Trump it's funny the other
night I went with my wife over to a
place in Los Angeles called the Magic
Castle Magic Castle was just spectacular
it's a lot of fun and went there for a
10th anniversary and one of the
magician's there who's this very famous
magician he's got a show on Netflix I
believe he started off his little
routine with a with a joke about Trump
he said I was in New York and everybody
cheers and then he goes and I walked
past Trump Tower and everybody starts
booing and I thought to myself really
like this is this is how you're going to
signal to your audience that you are one
of them all these rich people sitting at
the Magic Castle in Los Angeles on a
Tuesday night and you're and you're
talking about how you walk my Trump
Tower boom I mean honestly I'm not I've
called balls and strikes
from the name me once you cheer for
President Trump when he said he walked
past from tower just the amount of smug
but the left has exude adhere that's why
they like struck the smug for them is
not it's not bug it's a feature it's
something that they really enjoy now
meanwhile President Trump has headed
over to Britain and there he's gotten
himself in a little bit of hot water so
he did an interview with the UK son
which is just a huge mistake and in this
interview with the UK son he ripped into
current Prime Minister Teresa Mason for
folks who haven't been following this
Teresa may is the Prime Minister of
Britain and she is also in serious
trouble
electoral II because if there should be
a no-confidence vote and they call him
the election Teresa may probably loses
her prime ministership to at least
somebody else within her party and she
possibly loses the entire her party the
the Conservative Party may in fact lose
the entire election to Jeremy Corbyn and
the hard left
socialists I mean Jeremy Corbyn is an
actual former Soviet asset inside the UK
Jeremy Corbyn is an actual terrorist
sympathizer he's one of the worst people
on planet earth Jeremy Corbyn he could
be the next Prime Minister of Britain if
the Conservatives blow it while the
Conservatives have been fighting amongst
themselves over how to handle brexit
says recall a couple of years ago Bret's
it was voted on by the British public
and they voted that they wanted to exit
the EU and it was unclear what exactly
that meant how exactly were you gonna
carry out this exit from the EU so there
have been two plans that come forward
one is is sort of called for shorthand
soft brexit and the other is hard
breaths and hard brexit is we are going
to cut off all of the current treaties
that we have with the EU and renegotiate
all of them soft brexit is we are going
to exit in certain areas but we're going
to leave a lot of the rules in place in
other areas so as the Sun describes it
the Tory manifesto vowed to withdraw
Britain from the single market and the
customs union so we can end free
immigration and quit the EU Court but
labour has not signed up to that
approach a soft brexit would see the UK
have a similar membership of the
European Economic Area to that of Norway
that would mean that the country would
still have access to the single market
while being able to make deals without
the rest of the EU so they could make
outside deals it would also see the UK
stay within the EU customs union meaning
exports would not be subject to border
checks or tariffs and a softer brexit
could see the UK making payments into EU
budgets and accepting the Four Freedoms
movements of goods services capital and
people so it wouldn't be a complete
brexit so soft brexit is unpopular with
the hard base of support that supported
breakfast brexit hard brexit is more pop
hard brexit is not popular with the vast
majority of the british pub
so Teresa may has been having to walk
this very fine line well thankfully she
has the the subtlety of Donald Trump to
help her guide her through this Donald
Trump is about as subtle as a brick
through a window and so Donald Trump
comes in and he starts preaching to
Teresa may exactly how she should handle
Breck said obviously based on his vast
experience with the British public the
reason this is stupid
is because you don't want to undermine
your ally there if you undermines Teresa
May then Jeremy Corbyn could easily
become prime minister and then he has to
deal with an open socialist who hates
Trump hates the United States hates all
of America's other allies does Trump
really have that much of an interest in
how brexit is negotiated that he wants
to undermine Teresa May and yet there he
was praising Boris Johnson another
member of Teresa Mays cabinet who just
resigned over her soft breasts it stands
heroes Trump praising Boris Johnson
saying he'd make a great prime minister
boosting an actual competitor to Teresa
may within her own party in an interview
at the UK Sun I think he's a great
representative the floor for your
country I'm not pitting one against the
other I'm just saying I think it'd be a
great prime minister yeah I think he's
got what it takes and I think he's got
the right attitude to be a great grand
minister okay so he starts off by
basically boosting her actual her actual
antagonist inside her own party then he
rips into South Brett's and saying
that's not what the Brits voted for now
again maybe you agree with him that's
not the point is this politic at all is
this in any way smart or diplomatic if
you don't like how brexit is being held
first of all it's an internal issue for
the British public second of all like I
presume that Donald Trump wouldn't want
Teresa May traveling over to the United
States and dictating to me how we ought
to do our tax policy or our tariff
policy I assume that he'd get mad about
that but he's going over there and
telling him telling Teresa May that she
ought to basically renegotiate all her
trade deals with the EU which makes no
sense by the way because the amount of
trade that Britain receives from the EU
surpasses I think by a buy a bundle the
amount of trade that they receive from
the United States here he is in any case
ripping soft brexit saying that is not
what the Brits voted for well I think
the deal that she's striking is not what
the people voted on it's a much
different deal than the people voted on
it was not the deal that was in the
referendum
okay playing expert on stuff that you
really don't know much about is is
really not smart I'm not an expert on
brexit I certainly know Donald Trump is
not an expert on brexit either and
creating a binary choice between the
u.s. and the
you for the UK is just not smart policy
it's not smart policy US exports UK
exports to the US were worth about a
hundred billion pounds in 2016 compared
to 234 billion pounds to the EU in 2016
in other words if they have to choose
between the EU and the United States
with regard to their trade policy I
don't think it's going to be any
question that they're gonna pick the EU
because it would be foolish otherwise
otherwise okay so that wasn't all the
Trump had to say Trump then continued if
he was talking with the UK son some more
and he ripped Institute Sadiq Khan Sadiq
Khan is the Mayor of London and here's
the president ripping into Sadiq Khan
now this is the part where Trump
actually says some stuff that's true you
have a mayor who's done a terrible job
in London it's done a terrible job look
at the Terrorism that's taking place
look at what's going on I think he's
done a terrible job I agree with Trump
here but at least if you're gonna attack
your opponents as heck your opponents
when you are abroad okay with all that
said the presidents of the United States
is making a lot of waves over there it's
not stopping the hilariously enough it
is not stopping the left from making
even greater fools of themselves than
they otherwise would we'll talk about
that in just a second first honestly
thanks to our sponsors over at wink so
do you need a drink because damn I need
a drink I mean let's be straight about
this and if you do need a drink but you
actually want a nice bottle of wine like
you don't know the difference between a
bottle of Manischewitz about all
turpentine and a bottle of decent wine
then perhaps you ought to check out our
friends over at wink wink makes it easy
to discover great wine it's winc it's a
great resource it makes enjoying
downtime that much easier links wine
experts select wines match to your taste
personalized for you shipped right to
your door starting just thirteen bottle
its bucks a bottle there's nothing like
coming home to a box of delicious wink
wine selected just for you it's the best
day of your month fill out Winx palate
profile quiz and then answer simple
questions your average store clerk
wouldn't ask or translate into a
recommendation questions like how do you
take your coffee or how do you feel
about blueberries and then wink sends
wines curated directly to your taste the
more wines you rate more personalized or
monthly selections each month there are
new delicious wines like the insanely
popular summer water rose a no
membership fees skip any month cancel
anytime
and shipping is covered so if you don't
like about all they send you they'll
replace it with a bottle you'll love no
questions asked discover great wine
today
it really is great they customized it
just to your palate go to try wink calm
slash Ben you get twenty bucks off your
first shipment that's t ry winc calm /
Ben for 20 bucks off try
calm /ban for $20 off again try winked
calm / been to let them know that we
sent you okay so none of this is
stopping the leftists in the UK for
making the same sort of fools of
themselves that left us in the United
States have as well so they started off
by flying a baby Trump balloon over the
over the Westminster okay so there's a
lot of talk about how big this thing was
going to be and there are a bunch of
pictures of it they they basically
suggest it was going to be a blimp sized
baby Trump balloon that was flying over
once Westminster Abbey which is really
close to Parliament and here is the
actual size of the balloon that they
flew that thing is not even the size of
like a small bounce house okay that's
that's what you order from Amazon versus
what comes in the mail right there right
that's it that's your profile and tinder
versus what you look like in real life
that is a that is not what they were
going for and yet and yet there it is so
the left is you know doing wonderful
work over all of us and then Jeremy
Corbyn he says that Trump is best
friends with Teresa May and it's just
terrible why would Theresa May be
friends with Trump this is why Trump
should not have have undermined Teresa
May but Jeremy Corbyn this old loom bag
I mean he makes Bernie Sanders look like
a model of propriety insanity Jeremy
Corbyn here's Jeremy Corbyn going off on
Theresa May Theresa May has invited
President Trump to this country at a
time when he's dangerous and inhumane
policies are putting the lives and the
well-being of millions of people at risk
the Labour Party is committed to
dialogue including of course with those
we strongly disagree with okay so Jeremy
Corbyn using this as an opportunity to
rip into reach Theresa may this is why
you know I I know that the Trump policy
is basically going to he's a bull in a
china shop with everything and sometimes
that's great sometimes that's great
sometimes the China needs to be broken
I'm not sure our relationship with
Teresa may needs to be broken at this
time with Jeremy Corbyn sitting there
waiting to pick up all of the pieces now
that doesn't mean that everything that
Trump has said in Britain is wrong some
of the stuff he said in Britain is right
here's Trump for example talking about
immigration into Europe and people are
taking this as Trump's a racist know
what Trump is saying here is that lack
of assimilation into Western
civilization creates all sorts of
cultural problems he's not the first
person to say stuff like this David
Cameron former conservative prime
minister of UK
the same thing Angola Merkel has said
the same thing here is from talking
about mass immigration into the EU I
just think it's changing the culture I
think it's a very negative thing for
Europe I think it's very negative I
think having Germany and I have a great
relationship with Angela Merkel great
relationship of Germany but I think
that's very much hurt Germany I think
it's very much hurt other parts of
Europe oh yeah and he's exactly right
about this I mean I was in France a few
years ago and there's no question that
there are certain districts in France
that are just not safe for Jews to
travel and everybody knows about them
and that has been in effect of unvetted
mass migration into the EU it's one of
the reasons brexit happened in the first
place was people in Britain said we
don't want free travel of people all
around the EU they come and they settle
in Britain and then they just stay here
and they create enclaves they're not
assimilated in any way Trump was also
asked about Vladimir Putin he's supposed
to be with Vladimir Putin next week and
he was asked about whether he would talk
about election meddling with Vladimir
Putin I don't think Trump is wrong about
this one either I know you'll haskó will
we be talking about meddling and I will
absolutely bring that up I don't think
you'll have any G I did it I did it you
got me there won't be a Perry Mason here
I don't think but you never know what
happens right but I will absolutely
firmly ask the question okay and he's
exactly right about this as well he
should ask the question nobody should
expect in Vladimir Putin is gonna come
out and admit guilt in any of this but
the presidents of the United States is
going to have to at least be a bull in a
china shop with Putin as well he can't
just be a bull in the china shop with
regard to your own allies that's a safe
space to be a bull in a china shop you
know that the UK and France we're not
gonna spend their days attacking you
because it would just be foolish but
what you can do is attack in the same
way Putin that you would your own allies
I think that's the very least Trump
should do also I just got to say you
know President Trump can say all these
things some of them are true some of
them are not true what he shouldn't do
is fib outright so President Trump was
asked about the son interview and then
he called it fake news and unfortunately
there was a story that was done which
was you know generally fine but it
didn't put in what I said about the
Prime Minister and I said tremendous
things
and fortunately we tend to record
stories now so we have it for your
enjoyment if you'd like it
we record when we deal with reporters
it's called fake news and we solve a lot
of problems it's it's not it's not fake
news it was I just played you the tape
it's it's not actually it's it's not big
news so this is just something where I
wish the president would stop doing it
okay so I want to get to the mailbag I
have a lot of mailbag to get to today so
let's you know let's let's just jump
right in also we are in fact as of right
now awaiting some breaking news with
regard to with regard to the DOJ Rob rod
Rosenstein is supposed to be having a
press conference momentarily at which he
announces some new indictments in the
Muller in the Mulder case so we'll
report on that as it comes down in just
one second but we'll start with the
mailbag until then so we begin with
Brandon Brandon says mr. Shapiro with
the rapid growth of social media and
other internet news outlets you think
mainstream media is a dying medium for
information and so how long until the
majority of people move from CNN to
owning tear-filled tumblers thanks well
I do think that as people shift how they
are going about their business of
consuming news there will be a climb in
the ratings for a lot of cable news
networks just because younger people
have cut the cord in a way that older
people have not that said I think that
the the cable news industry is obviously
thriving and robust right now if you had
to invest your money in a twenty year
plan for the future everybody is moving
online and this is true for a lot of the
cable news networks as well they're
starting to expend more resources to
move into that space I think at a
certain point everyone will own the
tear-filled tumblr or the equivalent on
the left I think that the cable news
model in 20 years is probably not gonna
be a thing daniel says hi Ben love the
show my fiance just got her first
speeding ticket and she's very upset I
thought it might help her feel better if
you could talk about your experiences
with violating the law have you ever
been pulled over if not please pretend
like you have anyway Oh have I been
pulled over Daniel Oh have I been pulled
over so I used to own a baby-blue GT
Mustang convertible and it was awesome
except for the fact that if you drive
five miles over the speed limit and a GT
baby blue Mustang convertible you will
be pulled over whereas if you drive
precisely the same speed in a Honda
Pilot you will never be pulled over I
know this because since I started
driving a Honda Pilot I have never been
pulled over when I drove my baby blue
Mustang convertible
I was pulled over once every five
seconds I had many many parking tickets
my was driving tickets my worst speeding
ticket however was not in that GT baby
blue Mustang
verbal my word speeding ticket came in a
Honda Civic and I was in Honda Court
Ahana court I was driving I was caught
going a hundred and I was ticketed at a
hundred and fourteen miles an hour on
the i5 coming south from Sacramento and
it was it would mean honestly I was to
say I was distracted be to understand
there was a close family friend who just
died I was trying to get back for the
funeral but that said I was going 140
miles an hour and I was lucky because
they didn't catch me going 127 which was
where I maxed out in any case after that
it was it was it was not a great
experience shall we say they decided to
charge me with a misdemeanor rather than
a felony can be charged with a felony if
you if you're going that fasting put you
in jail they decided to try oh no sorry
they would have been a misdemeanor but
they could have charged a misdemeanor or
they could have charged me with like an
unsafe driving kind of not quite a
misdemeanor thing and so my license was
suspended for 30 days I had to go up to
I think this Victorville and go to go in
front of a judge in the middle of
nowhere and basically acknowledge my
crime and it was a good thing that I had
my dad drive me up there reason why not
I would not have been able to drive back
so that would have been really not great
so yes I have experience in speeding
tickets that said here is my general
opinion of speeding tickets did I
deserve it in 1:14 you bet I deserved it
at 1:14 did I deserve it at 70 in a 65
zone no I didn't because I think that
speed limits are generally stupid really
I think they're generally stupid I think
we have reckless driving laws I think
that if you get yourself into an
accident that's your own fault but speed
limits are generally an idiotic thing
there are certain countries in like
Germany I believe there's certain areas
Germany like on the Autobahn where the
speed limit is basically non-existent
and I have not seen a huge increase in
the number of accidents because of that
so I think a lot of this is done I think
most speeding tickets frankly and
traffic tickets are way for the
government to raise money the government
likes raising money by ticketing people
and this is just one element of that
okay so we'll do some more mailbag in
just a second first you're going to have
to go over to Daley wire.com so go check
it out right now
Daley wired icon ninety-nine a month
gets you subscription to this the Ben
Shapiro show you get to ask live
questions in the mailbag right now if
your subscriber plus you get the rest of
the Clavin show the rest in the Noel's
show and for your annual subscription
ninety nine dollars you get this leftist
Cheers hot or cold tumbler look behold
the magnificence check it out it's
fantastic so
check that out right now and when you do
then you get all of those affirmation
glories plus check us out our Sunday
special is coming up this Sunday who's
on our Sunday special this Sunday
preggers right so done and dennis prager
is on our sunday special this Sunday it
was a really interesting conversation
chick said at YouTube and iTunes make
sure that you ding the bell when you
actually subscribe at YouTube just hit
that little bell right there that make
sure that you're notified when we have a
new video check us out we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
you
okay so let's get back to the mailbag a
quick update on the on the Rosenstein on
the Rosenstein thing before we get back
to the mailbag so I'm now hearing that
Rosenstein is set to announce
indictments for 12 Russian intelligence
officials for hacking I'm not sure why
exactly that is deeply deeply newsworthy
it's not an American who's actually
involved in the hacking and there's no
charge that these people are involved
specifically with the Trump
administration these are the first
charges by the Muller office directly
accusing the Russian government of
meddling in the 2016 presidential
election I think we all acknowledge
already that the Russian government was
meddling in the election so watch as
everybody goes nuts today but I don't
think that it's going to be that big a
deal okay back to the mailbag Brandon
says mr. Shapiro with the rapid growth
of social media and other internet news
outlets do you think mainstream media up
we got that one ready sorry back to
let's see Troy okay so Troy says Chief
Justice Shapiro I hope we'll hear that
by 2030 no chance how is the Chief
Justice chosen are they appointed the
position by the president or do the
justices pick the Chief Justice based on
who has control on the court so the it's
an appointed position the Chief Justice
it is not like they elected among their
friends and they hold the reelection
among their friends like when Roberts
was elected who was selected to the
court by it by Trump everybody knew that
he was going to become Chief Justice of
the Supreme Court because he was
replacing William Rehnquist he actually
have to replace the Chief Justice I
believe I don't think that it's like the
friends get together and decide to
change it Elise says if you could debate
any person living or dead in front of a
large audience who would you choose to
debate Bernie Sanders hands-down anytime
anywhere half my brain excised not a
problem Phillips says how do I get
Veronica from the GW chats marry me if
we get divorced what happens to our
tumblers well I don't know Veronica
Philip all I can say is that ladies love
the tumblers so if you pledge the your
tumbler will be hers forever no matter
what happens in the divorce I will
suggest that your shot with Veronica
will be much better because when you
pull your assets including tumblers
you're both richer for it okay Edward
says Ben I recently read Henry David
throws civil disobedience well I agree
with him regarding his philosophy of
non-violent protests he also criticizes
the notion that citizens should obey
laws we feel are wrong until the law has
changed even going so far as to say we
shouldn't pay taxes if we felt they were
going to be used for immoral purposes my
question is
where does this end there are plenty of
laws currently on the books that I
believe to be wrong and a plethora of
programs I don't want my tax dollars
funding so should we disobey all the
laws we don't like and not pay taxes or
they're just some laws like slavery that
are so egregious that we have to take a
stand against them if so what determines
those kinds of laws Thanks love the show
this is a serious question in the
history of American law and
jurisprudence and it's one that requires
a lot of thinking because the general
answer is you should obey the laws that
are the products of a system that you
can change from within if however the
laws are the products of a system you
cannot change from within and they are
so evil as to require you not to obey
them then armed rebellion might be
necessary so for example the American
Revolution was founded on the idea that
the founders were being taxed without
representation they had no capacity to
affect the change within the system and
therefore they had to rebel the the
there's a lot of there's a good case to
be made that that disobedience to slave
laws like this obedience to the Fugitive
Slave Act of 1850 but that was morally
justified because there was no real
chance of changing that at the federal
level that that that was something that
should have been disobeyed in practice
and that basically is what happened in
large swaths of the north now the idea
that you can disobey tax law I think
that's a little bit different simply
because tax law changes all the time and
you can actually can't have a pretty
market impact on how the tax law is both
created and interpreted John says Ben do
you have any advice for aspiring authors
especially with regards to publishing
and marketing your book well my advice
for aspiring authors is do some
reportage I go out and write something
that people like once you once you have
a certain level of notoriety you can
write whatever you want obviously it can
be Bill Clinton and write a mystery
novel with James Patterson but if you
are somebody who's up-and-coming and you
want to get into say the thought space
not that not necessarily the fiction
space but like the nonfiction thought
space then I would recommend you go out
and do some reporting my first book was
a reported book brainwashed all about
bias on college campuses it did really
well because it was new information
people didn't have when it comes to
writing fiction yeah I don't think
there's any real I don't there's any
real rule with regard to what kind of
fiction works and what kind of fiction
doesn't and what gets published and what
doesn't it seems to me that you can be
as marketable as you want to be and it's
completely subjective as to how these
books are selected which is why so many
bad books get published current says Ben
I'm aware I mean a conservative echo
chamber I ignore left sources because of
their condescending misleading or
unfactual hateful and poisonous speech
however Jordan Peter
slowly convincing me I should listen to
both conservative and liberal voices he
states the West's success depends on
both sides and we should be talking to
each other could you name a few
podcasters and/or journalists who
present the news and information based
on facts and their values and not their
party ideology or some far-left nonsense
I'm looking for the Ben Shapiro on the
left well yeah there certain people on
the Left who I actually enjoy talking to
I'm friendly with and whose stuff I I
enjoy reading so my favorite right now
is there there's a gal named Jane Costin
who writes over at voxcom now I'm not a
voxcom fan but I think Jane actually
tries to be thoughtful about how she
approaches these issues what's hilarious
about that is that I originally met Jane
after she wrote a piece ripping the crap
out of me in the New York Times saying
that I was that I was an emissary of
hollow bravery and then I she got in
touch with me and I wrote her back and
she said you know I hope you're not mad
and I was like why would I be mad like
people criticize me all the time but I
think she actually tries I think that I
think that Jake Tapper for in I think he
tries I think Jake tries I'm not sure he
always succeeds but I'm not sure any of
us always succeed
I think that there are some journalists
who do a better job than others and at
different times right I think Jake when
it came to for example that gun debate
in Parkland it was not doing the job but
I think Jake when it comes to covering
for example the when it come when it
came to covering the Hillary Clinton
email stuff I think Jake was
significantly better and asked some real
tough questions of people so you sort of
have to determine on a case-by-case
basis unfortunately trying to think who
else is is a good reporter on the left
mmm you know Maggie Haberman from time
to time there are some reporters at the
Washington Post who do a fairly decent
job some at the near attempt I'll try to
compile a list and put it out there
because I think there are some people
who are at least doing their best trying
on the Left AJ says hiya Ben last year a
week before my 28th birthday I purchased
my first house I'd always lived with my
parents and once I graduated from
college started paying some of the
monthly bills to help out as we agreed
my parents were great and let me stand
till I was financially stable enough to
live on my own I know some people think
parents should make kids leave the nest
upon reaching eighteen or twenty-one and
let them get by on their own I was just
wondering your thoughts about what age
one should move out and if you think my
parents are too easy on me love the show
and thanks for the thought-provoking
rhetoric you speak okay so here's my
perspective you have to tailor this to
the kid so after law school I came back
and I lived at home that was really not
a huge problem because
I could afford to live outside the home
my parents knew I was responsible it was
not a question to me sponging off my
parents I had a job it was just a
question of I was more comfortable
living at home because I like my parents
they liked me and there is no real rush
for me to go out and get dept so you
know that's that's one thing it's
another thing if you are enabling and if
a parents is enabling or if you are
becoming a sponge off your parents if
the idea is you don't want to pay the
bills so that's why you're staying home
or you're too lazy to get an apartment
or you don't want do your own laundry or
that kind of stuff then you really
should move out and your parents are not
doing you any any sort of great benefit
by not kicking out of the house they're
actually making your life worse in a lot
of ways I do think that you reach a
certain age and no matter what your
priority you really should get out of
the house I mean if you're if you're 25
26 years old living at home I think that
you should really start thinking about
getting an apartment move out live on
your own living on your own is something
that's worthwhile as a general rule now
Tyler says hey Ben what version of
time-traveling movies and TV shows do
you think is the most realistic examples
include the fixed timeline where nothing
can be changed like lost and the
Terminator and the dynamic timeline
where changes cause alternative
timelines like in Back to the Future
Thanks well I mean I'm reading a book on
time right now that I'm gonna recommend
next week there's a good case to be made
the time is actually an illusion that
it's something that human brains use to
organize the stuff that happens in their
lives but that essentially all time
exists kind of simultaneously and that
you are as a creature traveling through
this this this mixture of material and
and time that you are you're just
observing things in a weird way and
there's all these weird questions are
raised by quantum mechanics and
Einstein's theory of relativity there
are all sorts of weird questions about
how time actually works but if you were
to think in a timeline way no I don't
think that there is like a fixed
timeline no matter what you do it can't
change I think that I'm not a
determinist I'm a frugal believer so I
think that there are such things as
alternative timelines if you could
time-travel also I just find movies that
that and an TV shows based on a fixed
timeline utterly boring because you know
what's gonna happen at the end anyway so
what the hell's the point chris says hey
man I have a question about the
Declaration of the Rights of Man and the
Declaration of Independence in the
Declaration of Independence the word God
and Creed are used in the document and
the Declaration of the Rights Man God or
creators not mentioned at all I know for
the Declaration of the Rights of Man
Marquis de Lafayette and Thomas
Jefferson were two of the main writers
with Thomas Jefferson
being the main writer of the Declaration
of Independence and the Declaration of
the Rights of Man wise God excluded from
the Declaration of the Rights of Man
also did Thomas Jefferson believe in the
same God that Jews and Christians
believe in or is he referring to
something else like how maximilien
robespierre was trying to force french
society into believing in the cult of
the Supreme Being or Dias beliefs also
was many of the ideas of maximilien
robespierre carried on to people like
Lenin Stalin Hitler and many others that
is a thousand questions all of them are
good fortunately I have a book coming
out next year that is on exactly this
topic and goes through all of these
questions one by one I will say in brief
that the difference between the American
Revolution the French Revolution is that
the American Revolution still paid
fealty to judeo-christian values whereas
the French Revolution in the memorable
phrase used at the time was all about
strangling the Last King with the guts
of the last priest so the idea was that
religion was an eminent bad and
overthrowing religion in favor of sort
of deist worldview was the best way to
achieve a reasonable Society obviously
that failed you have two more your
values to something and in America you
mordor those values to the
judeo-christian god Jefferson himself
and people say that he was a deist but
his deism was not just the sort of
clockwork God God made stuff and then
left it on its own there's there's a
good case to be made that he believes in
a slightly more involved God than that
although not a God who was constantly
involved in human affairs on a constant
level he believed that human beings with
the reason were more likely to shape the
world around them but he did believe in
the natural law and the idea that the
universe had been constructed according
to certain laws that required certain
human behaviors right this was common to
virtually all the founders Washington
believed those Adams believe this
Jefferson believed this I mean listen
there's something called the Jefferson
Bible or Jefferson tried to go back and
reorganize the Bible and and try to make
it sound more reasonable basically so
this is not somebody who's trying to
disconnect the people from the Bible as
a general rule Maslin says hey Ben i
watch your show every day I'm a huge fan
I'm a conservative leaning libertarian
in a relationship with a wonderful woman
who shares my values we've been together
almost a year my question is how long in
your opinion should you be in the
courting phase before you propose
follow-up would be how long till you get
married many of my leftist friends view
things as an immediate satisfaction
rather than a long-lasting happiness so
I get conflicting info thank you love
the show okay well if you know you love
her and she loves you and your share
values the answer is proposed to her
today and get married tomorrow
like seriously there's no reason to
delay things I'm speaking as somebody
who got engaged my wife after three
months of dating and got married to her
after eight months of dating okay then
that's just because
it took that long to get the wedding
together okay so it's and we've married
for ten years and we're quite happy when
you share values there this idea that
the longer you live together with
somebody the more you are likely to live
together well with somebody is belied by
every statistic people who live together
before marriage you actually are less
likely to stay married over the course
of time because you already know each
other's flaws so what exactly the whole
purpose of marriage is that you're
taking a leap of faith into a
relationship with a person who's going
to develop over time but if you share
values then you have something to Hue to
but if you are in a situation where you
are attempting to to you know
bust through all of the flaws you know
about each other already because you've
been dating for seven years it's a lot
harder to get the enthusiasm up for I'm
going to sign up for another thirty it's
a lot easier to do this in the very
beginning this is why marriage was built
around the idea of passionate love and
marriage was built around the idea of
companionate love so marriage at the
outset dating is built around passionate
love marriage is built around
companionate love companionate love
overtime there charts that show that's
basically the Jonathan Hite talks about
this and in the in the pursuit of
happiness his book and happiness
hypothesis his book on happiness
basically he says the relationships
start off like this here is your
passionate level of love it is up here
and then in here down here is your
companion at level of love meaning the
amount of trust you have in the person
the how well you know the person how
predictable that person is and over time
in the first year basically the first
couple of years passionate love goes
like this and companion at level goes
like this and the marriage that you have
10 years from now is not going to be the
marriage that you have when you are
first married and that's not a terrible
thing but it does mean that if you are
if you are thinking that the here's the
mistake people make they start off
dating there's a lot of passionate love
no companion to love companion that love
increases passion to love decreases but
then they look around they go this isn't
as exciting as it was when we first were
dating which is true right being married
10 years is not as exciting was because
there's not as much uncertainty you know
the person they're predictable you know
all their habits right all of this is
true living with someone makes it it is
not as exciting because excitement
generally comes from uncertainty there's
a lot more certainty when you lived with
someone for a very long time well when
that's the case and the question is how
do you get from passionate love to
companion to love and stay in Campania
11 be satisfied with companion at love
and the answer is the marriage was
designed marriage was designed to hem in
passionate love into companion love it
was
not designed there was supposed to be
this gap okay passionate love was
supposed to immediately move into
marriage the beginning of your marriage
was passionate and then that would
gradually move into companionate love if
you do that while you are dating then
you're basically at low ebb with
passionate love and then you think well
what happened to the passion when you're
married you know what happened to the
passion is you built a life together
when you're not married what happened to
the passion is you just hung out
together for too long a time and you're
bored with the person why don't I go
search for the next passion and
experience and this is the problem that
people have really they're looking for
that next tie they're looking for that
next tie and that's not what marriage is
about marriage is not about the highs
marriage is about the lows hey marriage
is not about the best times you
experience with each other it's about
what do you do when the bleep hits the
fan okay and that's the stuff we're
companion to love matters a lot and
passionate love matters almost not at
all okay so let's do a couple of things
I like and then a thing that I hate so
thing I like today so we're doing a lot
of Civil War stuff this week so I
decided I would recommend a book on the
Civil War this book is the battle cry of
freedom by James McPherson it's probably
the best the single best volume on the
Civil War that's been written about 600
pages and it's really easy reading
that's starting from before the Civil
War and going all the way up through the
end of the Civil War by James McPherson
won the Pulitzer Prize it's it's really
well written and very comprehensive it's
got all the maps the Ken Burns the Civil
War series draws heavily on battle cry
of freedom go check that out if this is
a period of time you're interested in I
have heavy interest in the Civil War I
think it's fascinating I think all of
the the philosophical issues leading up
to the Civil War are fascinating I think
the characters are the people who fought
in the Civil War are fascinating and if
you don't know the Civil War you don't
know America so go check it out battle
cry of freedom by James and Macpherson
ok time for a quick thing that I hate
all righty so Sasha Baron Cohen you know
we now know that he tried to prank Sarah
Palin into doing a bit on a series with
him and apparently what he did is he
said that he was a wounded veteran who
wanted to talk with her for a series on
Showtime and according to Breitbart news
which has deep connections of Palin's
I'm sure this is true Cohen pretended to
be a disabled veteran from Kentucky who
is a big fan of governor Palin he was
wearing a necklace made of bullets and
had a laptop covered in infowar stickers
the bullet necklace and stickers for
Alex Jones's Infowars website were part
of the persona Cohen was playing
according to the source
his
guys was basically a caricature of a
conservative middle-class Trump voter
who's asking her absurd racist
homophobic sexist questions they were
all meant to mock Trump voters as a
bunch of ignorant and offensive Kooks
some of the questions focused on Palin's
support of the Second Amendment
who's asking her things like why can't
the mentally ill be armed with assault
weapons he kept presenting her with
ridiculous graphs that she would told
him were obviously inaccurate and fake
and throughout it all Palin patiently
and politely explained why he was wrong
he added that her entire interaction was
over two hours long Palin has no doubt
it will be heavily edited to embarrass
her and then here is what Showtime had
sent to Sarah Palin what she may talk
about we'd love to discuss his putt his
background why she got into politics for
personal story her experience in career
in Alaska and on national level as well
we'd love her insight on the past
present and future of America it's a
free forum to talk about issues that
matter without being attacked show her
perspective without bias directly to our
audience this is a great way to connect
with a younger generation of voters so
this was show time basically lying to
Sarah Palin now as somebody who has done
a book that was based on people thinking
I was someone that I was not you cannot
lie when you do this so when I was so
the reason that people thought I was
someone I was not when I wrote for
example primetime propaganda is because
they assumed something that was not in
evidence I said that I was writing a
book about the history of Hollywood and
then I wanted to interview the most
important people in Hollywood and then I
was a Harvard Law School graduate a
simple Google search would have shown
exactly who I was but all of these
people in Hollywood were too lazy to do
that they saw the last name Shapiro they
saw Harvard Law they figured I was a
leftist and so I asked them questions I
asked him if I could tape they said yes
I taped and then I released the tape
that's not the same thing as what this
person : did to Palin because that's not
his routine right it's comedic comedy
routine
but the level of scorn that the left has
for Trump voters that they're all
rednecks who wear a bullet necklaces and
and watch Infowars it's it's quite
insane it's quite insane keep doing this
left keep doing it you want Trump to be
reelected you are well on the path I
mean you are you're gonna make that
happen in pretty short order okay well
we will be back here at next week with
all of the latest i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire Ford publishing
production copyright Ford publishing